okay I'm gonna tell you right now okay
you're committing the crime of trespass
the park is closed you have to leave
okay you're under arrest an Oregon
journalist now suing the City of Medford
two years after she was arrested while
reporting on a story you're under arrest
I'm just doing that
she's not she won't leave okay
it happened at the height of the
covid-19 pandemic in September 2020
public radio reporter April arelick was
reporting at a public park as police
worked to remove homeless campers can I
help you I'm I'm a reporter
okay so what you need to do is you need
to go out there and contact Trevor
Arnold if you do not leave the park and
I'm I'm recording on this body cam
footage shows aralick repeatedly stating
she was at a public park doing her job
you're trespassing I'm not trusted yes
you are it's a public park the park is
closed when airlik refused to leave
officers told her she was under arrest
okay you're under arrest you're under
arrest I am a reporter
was later charged with trespassing and
resisting arrest
trial was set to begin both misdemeanor
charges against her were dropped
please don't resist stop resisting on
Wednesday airlick announced she was
filing civil suit against the City of
Medford Medford Police Department and
Jackson County Eric argues the arrest
violated Her First Amendment rights of
Free Press and free speech and that it
prevented her from doing her job
took to Twitter on Wednesday saying
quote when I refuse to leave multiple
officers twisted my arms behind my back
and kicked at my legs and feet Eric also
says she was humiliated and traumatized
tweeting quote I was jailed for several
hours I was never given an opportunity
to call my editor my family or a lawyer
during that time they subjected me to a
full booking process including a highly
invasive strip search for the latest
developments in this story and all
things True Crime stay with long crime
Network I'm Sierra Gillespie